a mashed potato and gravy vending
machine and these custom personal urns
look like your head and store your
cremated ashes Vsauce Kevin here this is
mine
gives me is a telepresence device that
transmits your kiss it can measure and
translate the lip pressure shape and
movement of both user's lips and
reproduces it all in real time the
Singapore based developers lavada --qs
see this technology being not only used
in human to human interactions but also
human to robot human to virtual
character and robot - robot so yeah face
is a realistic humanoid designed to
mimic human facial muscles and
expressions the system dubbed the hybrid
engine for facial expressions synthesis
utilizes 32 motors underneath polymer
skin and the facial action coding system
which categorizes facial expressions
based on muscle hello my name is upside
down cat neurologist at Washington
University in st. Louis are reading
monkeys minds by analyzing the activity
of large populations of neurons they
discover what actions the monkeys were
planning before they made a single motor
movement basically a monkey put its hand
in the center of a table and was told to
move into a different area
when obstacles were introduced they can
see the different strategies for
overcoming them in the neural activities
before the monkey physically moved
enable talk our special sensory gloves
that give a voice to sign language
developed by Quad Squad a Ukraine team
the gloves are fitted with flex and
touch sensors and can translate sign
language into text and then spoken word
through a smartphone fur glove that
could improve sensation and motor skills
for people with spinal injuries there's
the mobile music touch developed by
researchers at Georgia Tech it works in
conjunction with light-up keys on a
keyboard and sends vibrations to the
fingers that should be playing that keep
indicating where and when to tap
remarkably participants have already
claimed to have regained some sensation
as a result of using this system look at
the arms on that bus yeah he must work
out to have an ecosystem on your desk
there's ecosphere a self-sustaining
ecosystem filled with filtered seawater
micro organisms
small shrimp algae and bacteria the
makers claim the average life expectancy
is two years but can see shrimp
populations thriving for seven years
inside these things and they were
developed by scientists at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory now say hello to
Aero graphite the new lightest material
ever made and has a density of less than
0.2 milligrams per cubic centimeter is
made of a network of hollow carbon tubes
grown at nano and micro scales it's
mostly just empty space but it looks
like a black sponge and can eventually
be used as part of an ultra lightweight
battery finally the V motion project
uses kinect technology to create a
visual instrument
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna leave you with the flame being
put out with sound and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]
hey Vsauce check out this clip of
Michael and I on pops pot slow as a mofo
show
[Music]
click here to watch a bunch of youtubers
in slow-mo and while you're over at pop
spot make sure you subscribe
[Music]